a certain conjecture about it and let me
just because the short talk jump right
into it and hoped at the end of the talk
you will see what this conjecture is and
why it's hopefully wrong conjecture so
yeah here's the outline of my talk first
we'll tell you what those conjectures
that I'm talking about here the idea is
basically the two simple properties one
is a compositional property and the
other one is a dynamical property bring
you more or less with one on theory and
the second part i will show you some
evidence for this conjecture which
somehow tell you that if you have to
ball state spaces then there's already
gives you one on theory and in the third
part i will speculate about possible
counter-examples while it would be
interesting and how they would be
related to interaction between through
your more systems okay so what's this
conjecture about well starting point
it's basically the same as truly your
starting point of a bit of a different
flavor it's this form a framework of
convex operational theories and the idea
is to formalize cert laboratory
situation certain processes for example
processes like this so you have
preparations transformations and
measurements and I will skip most of the
details of this framework since I'm
really using only a tiny little bit of
it in particular the most important
notion that will be using instead of a
state so stayed here is really whatever
comes out of the preparation device when
I press the button formally you would
say a state is mathematically described
as an equivalence class of preparation
procedures you see two preparations are
identical if everything that I do later
gives me the same outcome probabilities
for measurements so in in Julio's
notation actually this would be one of
these processes Omega which had a
trivial input and and some outgoing
system okay now we have signal States
but we can also collect all possible
States into state spaces so a state
space and I denote this by capital Omega
it's just the set of all possible states
that we can have on some given physical
system now there are two special cases
that you're all familiar with and one of
them is just classical probability
furio cpt here where the states are just
probability distributions so the state
space over n outcomes i omega m would
just be all these vectors with entries p
1 2 pn which are probabilities and sum
to 1 in quantum theory of a bit of a
different state space you have
superpositions of these alternatives
which basically gives you the density
matrices the N by n complex density
matrices but in general you could have
any kind of state space so here's here's
a bunch of examples in this framework
actually every compact and convex set in
some real vector space as a possible
state space and one famous possibility
is what's called the quantum bit or a
quantum two-level system so if you think
of a quantum bit in the usual way you
would say you have two states two
orthogonal states and you have a
superposition of the two and then the
superposition can always parametrized
and most of you will know it let me just
write it down midi once again by two
angles so you can write it as cosine
theta over 2 of 0 and sun sign and some
e to the IFI so it will be a state and
so you see that there are two angles
that parameterize estate and so you can
basically depict the state space as a
ball here the pure states are the
surface of the ball in the mixed states
are in the interior now a classical bit
would look like this this is a classical
binary alternative system so maybe you
have a coin and you could have hats or
tails or statistical mixtures of these
two alternatives which gives you this
line segment basically three level
system would have these three
alternatives and the statistical
mixtures so classically is something
like a simplex one fear it looks more
complicated it's quite interesting to
see what the quantum free level system
looks like so this picture is from a
paper by Tchaikovsky he try to depict
the three by three density matrices and
this is a great complicated convex
object that you get it's like an eight
dimensional beast with like lots of
symmetry but also flats on the boundary
and all kinds of weird features but in
general is
framework your state space could just
look like any convex set okay so here's
a more formal definition that's what
some of you will know in the context of
linear or the vector spaces or other
units phases it's actually if a set of
unnormalized states so these are the
normalized states and the pictures but
in general with unnormalized states they
will be closed convex pointing and
generating cones and some finite
dimensional vector space you can also
formally define what transformations
measurements are we just not do that
here because it's a short talk I want to
keep it simple but yeah this goes back
to also but what truly explained earlier
on okay now let's look a bit more
transformations what is the
transformation well a transformation is
something where a state comes in and the
state goes out so it Maps it's a it's a
map that meant to state to another state
and it should respect mixtures
statistical mixtures it means it must be
a linear map and we call that reversible
and the sense same sense is truly odette
namely if it has an inverse and the
inverse is also transformation so in
quantum mechanics these would really
just be the unitary you take a density
matrix you conjugated with some some
unitary matrix in classical probability
theory you basically take your
probability vector and you commute the
entries these are the classic blue eyes
of the transformation now if you look at
the geometry of your state space then a
reversal transformation maps that state
space into itself so it must be a linear
symmetry of it for example the quantum
case and the qubit this takes the block
ball and just rotates the block ball and
always map your states to pure states
okay now here's one thing that's one of
two properties or postulates that will
be interested in following and that's
called the reversibility postulate it's
somehow very natural property of state
spaces it says the following it says it
for every pair of pure states Omega and
Phi Swift to cure states there should be
a reversible transformation that map's
one to the other you can bring every
pure state or every other now this is
like a very nature all because you would
say well somehow if I have something
like reversible time evolution in
physics or if I build a circuit on a
quantum computer
then I can exhaust the full state space
I can go from any state to any other
pure state it's definitely true in
quantum theory any classical probability
theory and you can also think of
composing two of these transformations
give a group of his transformation so
this brings in mathematically the power
of group theory into the framework and
for that to work you actually get some
sort of symmetry in your state space for
the quantum bit obviously you can take
it and you can you can rotate your block
ball that works very nicely or if your
state space would be a square then your
cure states would be the corners and you
can rotate it by 90 degrees so that also
satisfies the postulate but in the
middle here you would have a state space
it's not symmetric enough there would
not be any transformation any symmetry
that map's the one pure stage to that
other pure state here for example so
somehow this brings in some symmetry
there's a second property that was
already mentioned the previous type
which is called tomographic locality and
this is all about composing systems so
what does that do well think of two
physicists Ellis and Bob and they have a
certain task so they are given a state
think of an entangled quantum state
Omega and say there's many copies of
that state you know the task is they
have to determine that state they want
to know what that state is by
measurement add something like
tomography you do measurements many of
them and then you get a description of
Omega and now what's true quantumly and
classically is that they can always do
that locally they just do measurements
on their half of the state and the local
laboratories and then talk on the
telephone and talk each other and tell
them the results they do not have to
make some kind of global measurement or
meet in the middle and get a hold of the
full state and that's what tomographic
locality means basically it says at
every state like this Omega here of a
composite system should be completely
characterized by the correlations of
measurements on on the individual
components
so from a more mathematical perspective
here's what you also can say you could
say well at first if I just take the
framework so far nff to state spaces a
and B Omega and Omega be there always
infinitely many ways to compose a mentor
a big estate space a be I just maybe
want a few constraints here maybe there
should be something like product states
which means I can it can identically
prepare a state on a and independently
estate on be I want to be able to do
independent measurement but that's
everything that still leaves many many
possibilities open the altima graphic
locality gives you is basically
something like a tensor product it tells
you that if you look at these vector
spaces that that carry the states then
the vector space of a B must just be the
tensor product of the vector space of a
and the vector space of B that's another
reformulation of tomographic locality I
think it's also mathematically very very
yeah natural to expect anything like
that now here's the conjecture that I
will discuss in the following the
contact sure tells basically that these
two things give you quantum theory
period so in more detail if you have
some composite state space a B Omega a B
which is a locally tomographic composite
of some Omega a and some Omega B and if
a and B and a be all the three state
spaces satisfy this reversibility axiom
a repeal state goes to every other
reversibly arm and also if there is at
least one transformation on a B which is
not a product transformation then you
get a quantum state space or a subset of
quantum theory maybe get classical
physics for example which would be a
subspace of quantum state space question
reversibility means
specifically that the group of unitary
linear transformations acts transitively
or some group no they're some group you
can think of a weird state space at the
square for example yeah and this is
really a state space that has for pure
states the corners and the reversible
transformations could be the dihedral
group we have reflection 90 degree
rotation and that would map every one of
the four to every other one that would
be fine and that's not quantum in there
are no unitary see you want okay so
substrate like a honing in a real vector
space which has a group of like a
transitive verb action on this side of
pure stays exactly yeah if you have a
cone you have the corn days and the the
extrema points of the Condes you act
transitively on them by by a group
that's basically it and all this
property here but this tells you is that
you have the two systems and you have
some reversible map maybe a circuit or
you know time evolution and what you do
not want is that all that can happen in
physic is just a involves independently
of be there should be at least one
transformation which makes the systems
talk to each other okay why is this
interesting well so first of all if the
conjecture is true I would say that it
gives a very very nice and clear idea or
answer to the question why do we have
bottom view in physics because somehow
reversibility is very important in
physics some graphic localities variable
motivated and if that brings you down to
quantum theory then it's an
understanding but actually I hope the
context is wrong this would be much more
interesting that'll be interesting in
physics mathematics and computer science
I think because if it's wrong that it
would have these other theories which
are not go on to them but have these
nice properties so it's physically
interesting because that could describe
some possible new physics or alternative
physics they could try to go out and
test for it mathematic would be
interesting because you know you have
these state spaces that have this nice
interplay between convex geometry group
theory and multilinear algebra and in
computer science you might want to take
these other theories and contrast them
to quantum computer
and see what their computational power
would be so that would be really nice if
we could disprove this conjecture here
and really construct some non quantum
theory of that kind okay now what about
the contractor will here's some evidence
that the conjecture is true
unfortunately which nevertheless I think
is in itself interesting so let's look
at this one one example for when the
conjecture is true so among all these
states bases that I talked about there
are ones that are kind of very naturally
describing bits or two-level systems but
with binary alternatives and these are
the ones which have a Euclidean ball as
a state space for example the quantum
bits is one example with the block ball
but actually the classical bit is also a
ball so it's like a one-dimensional ball
and you can always distinguish the North
Pole for example perfectly from the
South Pole but not more and the state
spaces showed up in many places in
physics for example if you do quantum
theory of the reals or the quaternions
of the octo neons then you find also
these block balls but of dimensions 2
and 5 and 9 for example and so what did
we do in this paper here now we said
suppose we don't have only one of these
bits but even a two of these bits and
both are described by one of these ball
state spaces now that's actually as in
the conjecture assume that they are
composed in a tomographic le locle way
and there's reversibility for a B and a
B and let's see what we can get so the
first thing that you find is if you want
reversibility then you have this
transitivity properties or every pure
state can go to every other this means
that the group of reversible
transformations on one of the balls must
be one which is transitive on the ball
so you can look at what groups are
transitive on the ball and then you find
this list here in the literature so for
example the rotation group is transitive
on the ball but there are other groups
that are also transitive on the ball you
can look at all of them and you can make
one additional assumption that we had to
do here namely whatever you can do on AE
so every transformation on a be the
screw
is actually connected for which is
physically reasonably thing can do
nothing and you can you know do a little
bit more than nothing and so on so there
will be a li group a connected group and
if you make these assumptions that I've
again listed here then you can just push
the following theorem so among all
dimensions of the block balls and all
transitive groups on one of the balls
there are only two possibilities first
you have a trivial thing where you the
group of transformations just the
product of the local groups this would
mean that you do something on a and
independently to do something on B and
that's all you can do and then that's
the other case which works only in
dimension 3 and only for the group so3
and it gives you that the coke global
group must be the unitary group of four
elements and the state space of a B must
be two qubit quantum states base let's
see only other possibility so in
particular if you ask that these two
balls talk to each other continuously
reversibly then this is only possible if
they are three dimensional balls and you
have standard complex two qubit quantum
theory yeah yes you can swap them but
the swap would then not be in in the
current in the connected component of
the identity yeah good point mmhmm yeah
so yeah
okay so how do we prove that something
sketch well we think well suppose we
have some generator on a bee that
generate some transformation we have no
idea what that is what that looks like
some danyoung thing but then since we
happily algebra we can use always the
algebra properties and you know do some
local rotations integrate over them and
this way construct some simpler Lee
algebra elements when we take these
simply algebra elements and see if they
preserve positivity of probabilities and
by this would we do here is we look at a
circuit or transformation we prepare to
local states then we let it evolve a
little bit according to this channel
rate and we do local measurements I we
load in a way such that for time zero
and there's nothing happening in between
here the probability is zero and since
probability must be positive we kind of
get that this this probability here must
be the local minimum 40 and then you can
get constrains on all these elements and
it shows you that if the dimension is
not three then all the generators that
you have must be non interacting like
the sum of two Hamiltonians basically
okay so that's one thing but now so far
we have looked at pairs of balls what
about more of them so obviously in
quantum theory we know that looking at
pairs is enough because we have this
nice property here on the circuit
diagram if we have three cubits and we
have a transformation then we can
decompose it and two transformations on
pairs only and that's why looking at
pairs is enough but you may ask well
maybe you know maybe this is just not
true and many other interesting theories
that are out there so and indeed a just
love Bruckner and Barry White Rock hit
shutout this interesting paper where
they conjectured that if we go beyond
pairs but say two three or four systems
then we get theories be on quantum
theory which satisfy local tomography
and reversibility but do not satisfy
this circuit property here so that would
mean for example that you have three
balls maybe they are four dimensional
and they interact in triple O's but they
never interact in pairs so you put two
of them together nothing happens you put
the third and suddenly of all these
possibilities showing up
they actually conjecture that you have d
balls and you've d minus one of them
then you can get a nice nice interacting
theory unfortunately so this is not work
with with Mario's chrome with my
students this seems to be wrong at least
we checked a few of these cases totally
found so far is the following so if if
the ball dimension is either 5 or 7 or 9
or 11 and so on and if you have at least
two of these balls maybe three or four
or five and the local group is just the
rotation group then there is no still so
there's no nice state space which has
tama graphically local interaction
unfortunately we don't know what's
happening for the even dimensions or for
the other groups but at least this this
is pros at least part of brokenness in
Turkish conjecture okay so just to sum
up what i've done here is i've given
your conjecture about local tomography
and reversibility implying quantum nurse
basically i explained to you that county
examples so that would be really
interesting very interesting physics
mathematics and computer science but we
don't know any of these counter-examples
yet and there's certain evidence for
this contractor named if you take pairs
of these blocked ball state spaces then
they can only interact reversibly in
this framework if the dimension is 3 and
you have to exactly the quantum state
space now our hope for counter examples
is to have more of these for a counter
example but maybe you know generalize
this from 2 to n systems make the same
conjecture maybe then you find context
samples here that turns out that this is
probably my student kills these now yeah
unfortunately so this conjecture still
stands okay thanks for your attention
[Applause]
pressed for time but your firm pressing
questions mostly conjecture is true I
mean it would be a bit of very very
striking thing but what we understand I
mean in a mathematical sense as if
they've quantum mechanics inevitable
conceptually it's not so clear is it why
should I should reversibility beer yeah
I mean you would say maybe from a
physics point of view you could say
there is a corner of physics a regime of
physics where we expect reversibility to
hold where we have time evolution the
usual sense and then this is very
natural but there might be other regimes
in physics maybe the regime of quantum
gravity where there's nothing like time
evolution the usual sense and then you
maybe wouldn't expect to find that and
indeed there is no this work on almost
quantum correlations for some or a bit
stronger than quantum correlations in
which people try to tell stories why
they might show up in quantum gravity so
that will kind of fit this narrative
that once you give up reversibility in
time with a continuous time evolution as
one of the ingredients that this is the
key to actually go beyond quantum theory
that speculation but maybe that could be
the way things are
ok so let the tech Marcus again
[Applause]